you cool
what does that mean truth is i'm
supposed to be in prison for what
superhero stuff what superhero are you
peacemaker get out of here there's no
superhero called peacemaker dude i'm
famous
[Music]
you're a born killer with expertise in
every weapon under humankind
i'm giving you the chance to stay out of
prison and work for me kill people bad
people
this is hardcore
your handler in the field
john economist tech and tactics
and this is our new recruit that they
bio
you don't have to shoot people after i
already killed them
right
who's the guy that's peeking out behind
the trash can vigilante's trying to be
helpful
our first target is senator royal and
goff golf may be traveling with his
family
are you sure those two kids came out of
those parents that's an attractive
couple and that one looks like it came
out of them but the other one looks good
about a baby a butt baby yeah my older
brother told me there's two types of
babies one that comes out normal and
then butt babies worst in every way they
come out of a woman's butt
well i believed i was a butt baby until
i was like 14. that explains a lot
there's something about him that's
sad
hey dad
i didn't much fun going to a nancy boy
like you
no lately i'm sticking up maniac hey no
no that's because we're born killers
what separates us from other killers is
we only kill bad people
usually
unless there's a mistake
you use being a jerk is a way to push
people away
you suck at powerpoint but if you just
drop that
people actually might like
you do you really wanna do you really
wanna taste it
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh my god
he's he's hugging me
he's hugging me dad grab my phone i
don't want to move
dad
[Applause]
you